make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with deceased
DC's zombies event and in reality I feel
like it was only ever a matter of time
before we saw that I mean to a degree we
got blackest night but blackest night
was more of a Green Lantern event than
it was I mean it did involve all of DC
but that was more of like we're not
doing this for the sake of doing zombies
we're doing this because we want to
bring some characters back and other
characters who want to leave dead right
like blackest night brought back pretty
much everybody who died and then like
brightest day basically kept the ones
they wanted but this is just a
straight-up like zombies event like
that's really all this is it's just like
a straight up DC zombies story and it
starts in one of the coolest ways ever
what this does is it initially picks up
with Darkseid now we get this kind of
like kind of narrative that goes through
they're like you know my mother always
used to say there were there was never
any such thing as monsters and so on but
it's interesting because Tom Taylor's
the one riding this and here's the thing
about Tom Taylor Tom Taylor is really
really good at writing stories that are
basically something akin to like
post-apocalyptic or if like things are
going crazy right like when it comes to
something like this this is where Tom
Taylor really really really shines and
this is kind of cool because it
initially picks up with like Darkseid
invading Earth right like and you've got
it you got some cool characters here
that you wouldn't normally see like
you've got Black Lightning who's here
and then you have your standard fare of
the Justice League now remember this is
like a whole different universe in DC
this is not an in continuity story as
far as I'm aware it's some it's
basically like a what-if story for
Marvel so because of that some of the
characters do look a little bit
different but you basically have
Darkseid showing up here in like the
Justice League defeats him right which
is what you would expect right I mean
usually whenever Darkseid shows up it's
kind of like the Justice League fights
them for a little bit and they defeat
him and that's basically the end of that
what's kind of ironic about this and
this is kind of a funny thing was kind
of ironic about this is remember in the
DC multiverse there's only one Darkseid
and he's currently in Justice League
Odyssey so this is one of those
scenarios readers kind of have to just
go with it and just say what the heck
ever you know I mean like if you're a
huge continuity stickler well then I
don't know what to tell you but it is
kind of cool because when they of course
wonder what I guess the last row of
truth around Darkseid and the way this
works is that those individuals who are
bound by the lasso are usually like
they're forced to answer whatever
question Wonder Woman asks
truthfully right and there's usually
week it's not really week but they're
usually like helpless within the
confines of the lasso with Darkseid
though this Amon is like you will not
return to our world say it the lasso
compels you to and Darkseid says yes I'm
not going to come back for your world
and then he just removes the lasso and
it's like because I have what I
for literally darkside overpowers the
lasso of truth which is cool but from
there we end up finding out that like no
one can find cyborg cyborg was in
Metropolis at one point along the line
he was basically helping till I deal
with all the parademons and all that
kind of stuff that came with like
Darkseid's invasion but nobody knows
where cyborg is anymore and that's
presumably wet Darkseid came for now one
of the cool little things that go on
here this is kind of important is a
little bit of character building this is
one of reasons why I say that that Tom
Taylor is really good at this Tom Taylor
is very good at capturing the nature of
characters and no matter what story
they're in making sure they stay true
right like Batman is a guy who doesn't
trust anyone and so it's almost Tower of
Babel esque in the sense that like
Batman pulls up his device that says
like like cyborgs nowhere around here
like well how do you know that is it
because I put a tracking device on him
because the guys got apocalypta in
technology he's basically like a walking
mother box he's essentially like a crazy
weapon he'd be stupid to leave him here
and there's a bit of distrust that comes
to the rest of the Justice League like
really man you're still doing this after
all this time but it makes sense it's
the nature of Batman's character now
from here we switch over to apocalypse
property now I remember apocalypse is a
is a is a world of pain and suffering is
really all it is it's the equivalent of
Hell in the realm of DC right like
you've got highfather on new Genesis
which is supposed to be equivalent to
heaven but my father's kind of a dick
and then you have apocalypse which is
supposed to be something akin to hell
they're not it's not actually Heaven and
Hell those do exist in NBC and the
vertical line but in terms of the main
DC superheroes what you never really see
that the concept of like vertigo with
like the presence of an Lucifer
Morningstar in those characters because
you never see them crossover with the
main DC superheroes they're largely
considered to be kind of isolated and on
their own even though they're really not
and so because of that apocalypse and
new Genesis is about as close as you get
to heaven in hell but because this is a
place of suffering and torment it's
literally cyborgs being hooked up to a
torture machine
and then basically being asked questions
and this is where the revelation comes
from that what Darkseid had been
pursuing was the same thing he always
been pursuing which is the anti-life
equation now again Tom Taylor really
like kind of knocking it out of the park
here it's designed to read it to bring
in new readers people who have never
really read DC and specifically have not
really read anything about the new gods
won't know what the anti-life equation
is the anti-life equation is a
mathematical proof that if you can
basically find it and and if you can use
it you can dominate the will of all
sentient beings in the universe is what
Darkseid's always been hunting for is
what he found during the events of Final
Crisis like it's it's
major part of the the DC landscape now
but where Darkseid has had one half of
the equation which is to say if you were
to use slope the equation y equals MX
plus B then what dark side basically has
is MX plus B he doesn't have y and so
what he's doing is looking for the other
half of the equation he's looking for Y
and it seems to have manifested itself
inside of Cyborg now the nature of the
anti-life equation is kind of strange
right like the equation is is its little
is it is a mathematical proof but it can
also is it's also sort of a biological
concept if you solve it and use it it
has a tangible effect and it'll spread
like a virus and that's exactly what
happens dark side basically takes the
anti-life equation and then he in turn
summons death and then in doing so
summoning the black racer he basically
takes a portion he takes the anti-life
equation and merges it with an aspect of
death essentially like I guess maybe
this twisted perception that the
anti-life equation can be used to kill
everyone but because of that because the
anti-life equation has been merged with
death it basically corrupts the equation
and when it does it sends dark sides
spiraling out right he just basically
loses his mind and succumbs to absolute
and pure madness and like the little
black racers like time for God to die
and desaad because of the fact that he's
basically immune to any kind of viruses
or anything like that any kind of
disease he's not infected by by
basically this corrupted anti-life
equation but in realizing what it's
doing the dark side sends cyborg away in
hopes it'll basically fix dark side now
of course this sends cyborg back to
earth but at the same time dark side
loses his mind and then destroys the
entirety of apocalypse and wipes all of
it out and so when cyborg lands back on
earth he brings the corrupted anti-life
equation with him and that's how the
zombie infection spreads it's actually a
genius idea a virus that's designed to
bend others to its will and then in turn
merge it with death basically bends
others to its well and turns them into
the walking dead it is super full and
it's a it really really works but kind
of drawing from Final Crisis because the
fact that the anti-life equation is a
mathematical proof and because of the
fact that cyborg is a walking talking
cybernetic organism that basically taps
into the Internet the anti-life equation
of the corrupted equation basically
leaves him and goes into the internet it
turns into Skynet and literally spreads
everywhere it goes all over the place at
every single form of social media to
everybody's phones spreads like wildfire
so it's very similar to what you saw in
spreading the anti-life equation and
Final Crisis which again makes sense but
because of the fact of the world is so
logged into social media those looking
at Twitter Instagram snapchat Facebook
the whole nine yards are all basically
blasted with this virus and in turn are
basically hit with like the corrupted
version of the anti-life equation and in
doing so like they all basically just
succumb to like these zombie monster
things but basically cyborg is the one
that starts off the the sets off the
whole zombie apocalypse but it's kind of
interesting here because in turn like
you have Superman talking to Scott free
talking to big Barda of course you know
mister miracle and basically saying hey
look guys like you know we got to find
cyborg so on and so forth but in the
middle of all that he basically takes
off because all he hears is screaming
only to realize like it's this whole
virus thing is spread across the world
now Superman doesn't initially know why
all this is happening and it's it's one
of these things that Tom Taylor kind of
passes over right like that's that's one
of the downsides to Tom Taylor Tom
Taylor can like hop skip and jump from
point to point to point and not fill in
the gaps and then kind of leave you
asking questions of will but like how
though and like what seems to have
happened is between the times like
Superman went out there and the world
was screaming and the time that we pick
up with Jonathan Lois and Damian Wayne
that basically Superman figured out that
this virus is being spread digitally now
we can kind of make some assumptions
here so maybe like in this universe
Final Crisis happened and like Superman
says okay this seems to be like the the
anti-life equation sweating through the
digital sphere like you did in Final
Crisis it could be Superman just like
analyzing these guys using whatever
vision he has but but regardless of the
scenario Superman comes to the
realization that it's spreading through
TV and social media and so of course we
have Jonathan going to find his mom's
phone and so on and so forth as soon as
he picks it up Superman destroys it when
he flies him through the window and then
destroys the TV screen it says nobody
look at anything everybody close your
eyes chill everybody relax
from there you switch over to Batman and
this is one of the coolest parts so
Batman you know being the detective that
he is is already on the case right like
Gotham's basically is lost
Batman shuts down like like the entire
connection of Wayne Manor to the
Internet's to the Batcave is not
connected to any of the Internet in turn
he has all these all these redundant
loops
he's got Gotham City on close to some
cameras so basically he shuts himself
off from the world and then in turn
starts analyzing all the footage that he
sees and realizes like the whole places
go into pot and when the question is how
many people are infected right now an
estimated 600 million people have been
affected in the first day the entire
world's population will be infected in a
couple days and basically that's it it's
game over and it's and it's cool because
from there Batman basically issues like
the EMP
for Wayne Manor shuts down the power to
everything Eman is is essentially just
kind of walking blunt but technology has
become the enemy of the world and that's
one of the cool things about about Tom
Taylor is there's always kind of a moral
tale right I mean Grant Morrison is
similar to that and I bring him up
because of the you know we've been
talking about Final Crisis the promise
Grant Morrison is nobody understands
what Grant Morrison is doing except for
himself and people who are fans who
think they know what Grant Morrison is
doing you know whatever but but
regardless of the circumstance like
there's always kind of a moral
cautionary tale when it comes to Tom
Taylor stories and it's the the like the
Internet is the enemy of the world like
social media is the enemy of the world
which technically he's not wrong but
what you end up having is like this this
kind of discussion between Lois and
Superman Damian and and Jonathan and
there's like worse Batman like it's
Batman gonna make it as it's kind of
cool to see because one of the things
that that really sort of made Amiens
such an interesting character is that
while he is cold blooded and ruthless
and in his an insanely talented killer
the fact remains he's still a kid and
it's cool to see that that child part of
him come out he's worried about his dad
is my dad going to be okay I love the
way that's done and so what you end up
doing is basically picking up with like
Batman kind of making his way through
Wayne Manor and looking for Alfred and
looking for Tim Drake no I'm sorry did
dick is who he's looking for Tim Drake
is who he's also looking for but what
Batman is of finding like once he finds
Alfred who thankfully is okay Dick
Grayson is not Dick Grayson has been
turned into a zombie so basically we
have Batman versus zombie Dick Grayson
and it's kind of cool it's pretty
awesome to see though in the middle is
whole fight where you have de Grayson
suddenly you're met with the arrival of
like Tim Drake and so basically you've
got zombie Tim Drake you've got zombie
Dick Grayson Batman's made to face off
against the both of them he tells Alfred
to run for his life and like the last
thing we see is Dick Grayson taking a
chunk out of Batman's neck Dick Grayson
who kills Batman but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button oh cliffhangers if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
cliffhangers peace